the price of bitcoin has been crashing
aggressively and there's tons of people
who are freaking out now of course
bitcoin's price has been down around 30
000 multiple times before and bitcoin
holders they've weathered 50 drawdowns
four times in the last four years but
even though the price is dropping
everyone's asking why the hell does
bitcoin keep going down and the truth is
that mostly it was large institutions
large financial organizations people who
weren't in the market before 2020 they
had acquired a ton of bitcoin over the
last two years but once we went risk off
in the environment and the macro
environment changed they started to sell
bitcoin bitcoin's the riskiest asset
that they have in their entire portfolio
but of course at the same time at those
large organizations those sophisticated
wall street people they all were selling
bitcoin well guess who was buying it
there's somebody on the other side of
that trade every single time it's the
people who are buying up tens of dollars
hundreds thousands and sometimes even
tens of thousands of dollars it's the
individuals the plebs in bitcoin they
continue to dollar cost average in
bitcoin and they simply are scooping up
cheap bitcoin now how do we know this
well if we take a look we just hit an
all-time high in the number of addresses
on chain that hold at least one bitcoin
there are now 848 939
wallet addresses that have at least one
bitcoin it's an all-time high we then go
and we take a look at the actual graph
itself we have it here overlaid in
orange with also the price in gray you
can see that over time anyone in the
world who continues to acquire bitcoin
we continue to see the number of wallet
addresses on chain crossover at least
one bitcoin and hitting that all-time
high price my guess is that over time
this is eventually going to cross over 1
million wallets on chain that have at
least one bitcoin in it and of course as
we continue to see bitcoin's price go
sideways and eventually recover that
value of that bitcoin is only going to
increase no matter what happens in the
world bitcoin doesn't pay attention
doesn't matter what the interest rate is
it doesn't matter what the geopolitical
uncertainty is it doesn't matter who's
holding bitcoin or who's not doesn't
matter what legislation is put forward
by states like new york and it doesn't
matter who's mining and who's not
bitcoin continues to do exactly what it
was designed to do produces block after
block after block of transactions it's a
decentralized computer system happens to
be the most secure computing system in
the world and naturally there are people
in the world who want to have a
programmatic monetary policy that is not
susceptible to the whims of individuals
bitcoin is the only system in the world
that has a monetary system where it does
not respond to changes in demand more
people want bitcoin bitcoin's monetary
policy does not change less people want
bitcoin bitcoin's monetary policy does
not change and naturally having some
sort of certainty in an uncertain world
is super valuable it's estimated that
over 150 million people around the world
already hold bitcoin and as we see here
there's now 800 000 or more people who
actually have at least one bitcoin in
their on-chain wallet the number's gonna
keep growing and bitcoin's gonna become
more and more important over time all
you have to do is keep looking at the
on-chain metrics even though the price
is down all sorts of different data
points are telling us bitcoin is growing
stronger bitcoin is growing more
decentralized it's likely that the price
is just missing what's actually
happening to the fundamentals hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time